in this video i'm going to show you how
to create this beautiful
responsive cross-platform twitter app
from scratch
and get it running and working on five
different platforms
so we're going to create an ios app that
you see here going to create an android
app
we're going to create a mac version of
our app
a windows version and we're going to get
this running
in a web browser as well as a responsive
single page application using viewjs
quasar framework and firebase this
course requires a basic understanding of
html css and javascript
and knowledge of vue.js would be
beneficial and before we get started i
just want to give a huge shout out to
free code camp for hosting this video my
name is danny i'm an indie app developer
and creator of a popular cross-platform
app called budget
and i teach vue.js web development and
cross-platform app development
on my youtube channel which you can find
at danny's dot link slash youtube and
the link will be in the description
what we're going to do here is create
this simple beautiful and responsive
twitter clone using vue.js quasar and
firebase
and it's going to have a simple twitter
style layout with a draw on the left
hand side
and this drawer can be toggled with this
button and we have links to our two
pages
the about page which is just a simple
content page
and then the home page we can enter a
tweet here with a 280
character limit so if we try and type
beyond that then it will stop us
so we can enter a tweet
and when we click this button it'll be
added to the top of our feed here
and we can also delete our tweets and
they'll disappear with this
nice animation and we can like our
tweets as well by clicking this button
and it's going to be responsive and have
a different layout for mobile
you can see the draw disappears and can
be toggled again with this button
i'm going to be using a firebase cloud
firestore database to
store all of our tweet data once we've
got this
running and working in the web browser
we're going to generate hybrid apps
which can be deployed to
all of the different app stores for ios
android
mac and windows and thanks to the
firebase cloud firestore database it's
going to have live data sync across all
of our devices
so if i add a tweet here on the web
browser
version and we look over here on the ios
version
we can see that new tweet pop up on the
ios version as well
and likewise if i delete a tweet on the
ios version
we see that tweet instantly deleted on
the web version
as well so how is it possible to create
this app for all of these different
platforms
well it's made possible by quasar
framework
[Music]
so what the flip is quasar framework
well it's an incredible new framework
which allows you to create a view gis
app with a single code base and deploy
it to
many different platforms so we can
deploy it to the web as a single page
application
a progressive web app or a server-side
rendered app we can deploy it to a
hybrid mobile app which can be deployed
to
the different app stores using cordova
for both ios and android
and we can deploy it to a desktop app
using electron
for mac windows and linux and it also
has
a huge material design component library
with hundreds of different components
such as buttons
lists
and tables and tons of different form
components
and you can just click on this button
for any component and grab the code
and just paste it into your app and
start using it and it also has tons of
different
utilities and plugins such as inbuilt
date formatting
the ability to store and retrieve data
using local storage and also dialog
loading and notification plugins which
make it really easy to
create dialogues and notifications and
stuff like that
it also has hot reloading on all devices
so when you change your work you see the
change instantly
even when you're developing mobile and
desktop apps
and it also has platform detection built
in
which means that you can for example
display a particular element or
component only on desktop and then
display a different element only on
mobile
or you can fire a particular block of
javascript code
only on mobile and then a different
block of javascript
on desktop so quasar is one of the most
versatile
frameworks out there at the moment
especially if your goal is to create an
app on multiple platforms
[Music]
let's get started by creating a new
quasar project
using the quasar cli so you want to go
to the quasar site
at quasar.dev and then get started
i'm just going to stretch this out a bit
and you want to go to quasar cli
and install quasar cli and you need to
have node installed
so you can get that at nodejs.org and
you might want the one on the left here
once that's installed you can then
install the quasar cli with this command
so i'm just going to copy that and jump
to my terminal which is just running
within
vs code which is the editor i'm going to
be using and you just want to run
npm install g at quasar cli
and if you have any trouble installing
that then you might need to add
sudo at the start and i already have
this installed so i'm not going to
install
it but once the quasar cli is installed
we can then create a new quasar project
with the quasar create command
so i'm just going to jump back to my
terminal in vs code
so you want to make sure you're in the
folder where you keep all your projects
and then just run quasar create
and you want to give it a name i'm going
to call it quitter
it's going to ask us for some options
here i'm going to leave the default
project name
i'm going to change the product name to
quitter
i'm going to leave the description and
i'll just enter my name as the author
and i'm going to choose sas with
indented syntax for the
css preprocessor and it's asking us for
our components and directives import
strategy
and i'm going to choose auto import
because this means that whenever we
use a new quasar component in our app it
will be
imported automatically which makes our
life a lot easier
and for the purposes of this video i'm
going to disable eslint
although you might want to consider
using that in your own projects
especially if you're working in teams
i'm not going to enable any other
options so i'm just going to hit enter
here
i'm going to choose yes use npm to
install the dependencies
okay it's finished creating our project
and if we scroll up a bit it tells us
how to launch it we just need to
cd into the folder and run quasar dev
and i can see the folder it's created
here
quitter so i'm just going to drag that
into vs code
then open up the terminal and just run
quasar
dev and we can now see our basic quasar
starter app running in the browser
and so by default we just have a simple
app with a simple layout we have a draw
along the side which can be toggled with
this button
we have a header along the top and we
just have a simple page with this image
and we have some basic responsiveness
out of the box so if i scale this down
you can see the left draw disappears and
again can be toggled with this button
let's take a quick look at the folder
structure of this quasar project
so in the root of our project we have
this quasar.com.js file
and this is the configuration file for
our project
and this allows us to do things like
install icon libraries
and set the view router history mode to
hash or history
and we can also install animations here
and plugins
and also configure our different modes
such as ssr
pwa electron code over etc
and the main folder we're concerned with
is this source folder
so in the root of that we have this
index.template.html
so this is our html page and we don't
typically need to change this much
and it just has this one div in the body
and this is where our main view
component will be loaded which is this
app.view file so this is our root view
component
and this will load the layout component
of our app here
which brings me to the layouts folder so
this is where the layout of our app can
be found this main layout.view file
and the layout is basically all of the
elements that surround the pages of our
app
so in this case this is the drawer along
the side and the header along the top
and within our layout we load
our pages and right now we just have
this one page with this
image in the middle and if i scroll down
to this
q page container component we have this
root of view component here
and that's where our pages will be
loaded which brings me to the pages
folder
so we'll place all of our pages in here
and right now we just have an error page
and this index.view page
which is this page here with just this
one image on it and we also have this
public folder where we can place images
and css files and things like that
and when we build our app anything in
this folder will be available
at the root so for example this favicon
will be available
at slash favicon.ico and then back to
our source folder we also have an assets
folder where we can also place images
and stuff like that
however everything in this folder will
be processed by webpack so you might
find that images
are converted to base64 and stuff like
that then we have this boot folder where
we place boot files
and a boot file basically allows us to
initialize a plugin or a package
before our app starts up and we will be
adding a boot file later on for
firebase then we have a components
folder where we can place all of our
view components
and a css folder where we have a global
css file
or sas file and we also have this
quasar.variables.sas file as well which
we can use to customize the colours of
our theme
and we will change our theme a little
bit later on
finally we have a router folder where we
configure our router
and if we open up this routes.js we can
see this routes array where we're
configuring all of our routes
so you can see it loads our layout file
at the root and we configure all of our
pages within this
children array and right now we just
have one path
to our index.view file which is this
page that we see here with just this one
image on it
[Music]
let's work on the layout of our app and
if we look at the twitter site
it has this two draw kind of layout with
one on the left and one on the right and
all of our tweaks and stuff
in the middle and quasar has a layout
builder that we can use to
generate a layout so let's see if we can
use that to generate a layout that's
similar to the twitter site so i'm going
to jump to the quasar site
and then layout and grid and then layout
builder
and it opens up this layout builder for
us and we basically just have to choose
all of the options we want
so we do want a cue header so we're
going to leave that enabled
we don't need a footer so i'll disable
that we want a left side drawer
and we want a right side drawer and we
don't need these navigation tabs so i'll
disable this option
and i'll click on continue and if we
look at the twitter site
the header doesn't go all the way along
the top it's just at the top of this
middle content column so if i jump back
to layout builder
we can play around with these options
here to generate a similar layout
so these options on the left are related
to the left
draw and the options on the right for
the right draw so if i click on this
l option here we can see that the left
drawer now goes all the way up to the
top
just like the twitter site and if we
choose this little
r option on the right we see the right
draw do the same thing so this is the
kind of layout we want with
our header just at the top of the middle
column and i don't really like this drop
shadow
on the header so under this header bit
i'm going to change this
separator type to bordered so we just
have a
bordered header then i'm just going to
scroll down and click on continue
i'm just going to disable this visible
footer option because we're not going to
have
footer then we can just click on export
layout
and it gives us an entire layout file
so i'm just going to copy this and i'm
going to jump to our layout file which
is in source
layouts and main layout.view i'm just
going to select everything here
and paste over our new layout and if we
hit save
we can see our app now has the kind of
layout that we're looking for
[Music]
let's make our header look a bit more
like the twitter header
and the first thing i'm going to do is
change our primary color to the
twitter blue color and our current
primary color is this blue color we see
in the background of the header here so
i'm going to jump to source
css and quasar.variables.sas
and we can use this file to customize
our theme colors
and we can see our primary color here so
i'm going to paste in the twitter color
which i have in my clipboard which is
just 1da
1 f2 and i'll save that and we now see
our header change
to the twitter blue color uh let's work
on this header a little bit
so i'm going to jump back to main
layout.view um we can see our header
here it's this cue header
component and i'm going to remove this
quasar image which is this
q avatar component so i'll get rid of
that and i'm going to change this title
which is in this queue
toolbar title component to quitter
save that and i don't want this right
hand sidebar to be
toggleable so i'm going to remove this
button here which is this
cue button component here so i'll get
rid of that and save that
and i want this header to have a white
background with black text
like the twitter header and if we jump
to the quasar site and then style on
identity and then color palette
then we have all of these different
colors that we can use in our app
and so if we want to set our text or our
foreground to a particular color then we
can just use a class such as text
dash and then the name of the color up
here
or if you want to set a background color
we can just use a class such as
bg dash and then the name of the color
and we see all of these different colors
and we don't see them here but we also
have
equivalent classes for black and white
as well
and if we look at our cue header
component here this currently has a
class of bg-primary
which is giving this header a background
colour of our primary colour which we
set in our theme file before and a class
of text
dash white which is giving it this white
text color
so i'm going to change this background
class to bg dash
white to give it a white background
color
and i'll change this other class to text
black
to give the text a black color and i
also want to make this title bold
because it's bold in the twitter header
and if we jump to the quasar site
and then style an identity and
typography
then we have all of these different
classes we can use to style our text
and if we want to make our text bold we
can use this text
weight bold class so i'm going to jump
to this q
toolbar title component which has our
title
i'll add a class of text dash weight
dash bold and save that and our heading
is now bold
so this header is now looking pretty
similar to the twitter header
let's make this left draw look like the
twitter left draw
with a nice logo at the top and then
links to all of our pages
so let's add a logo to the top first and
there's an icon component that we can
use for that so i'm going to jump to the
quasar site
and then a few components and icon
and so we can use this icon component so
i'm just going to click on view source
and grab the first one
and we'll add it to this left draw and
this is our left draw here this q
draw component so i'll get rid of this
comment and just paste in that icon
save that and we can now see that icon
on the page
and if i jump back to this icon page on
quasar
we can use all of these different icon
libraries material icons font awesome
ionicons and all of the rest and we can
use the material icons out of the box
so if i click on this link takes us to
the material icons page
and so we can use any of these icons and
all we need to do
is replace this name prop
with the icon name that we see here so
if we want to use this
accessibility icon we can just change
this name prop to
accessibility and save that
and we can see the icon update so we can
use all of the material icons out of the
box
but the other icon libraries need to be
enabled in our config file
and i want to use font awesome for our
logo
so i'm going to jump to our config file
and this is just in the root of our
project
it says quasar.com.js and i'm just going
to search for icons
and we can see in this extras array here
all of these different icon libraries so
to add the
font awesome icon library we just need
to uncomment this line
and save it and we can now use the font
awesome icons as well
so i'm going to jump to the font awesome
page
i'm going to search for bird and scroll
down
and this dove icon looks pretty good so
i'm going to click on that
and if we look at this example markup
here these classes that we see here
are what we need to use in this name
prop so i'm just going to copy this
jump back to our app and i'm just going
to paste in that
markup i just copied underneath this
icon then i'm going to copy these two
classes and paste them into this name
prop and then just get rid of this
i tag and save that and we can now see
our dove icon
on the page however i want this icon to
be much bigger and i want it to be
our primary blue color as well and if we
jump back to the icon page on quasar
and we jump down to this q icon api
all of the components in quasar have
this api section
which tells us which props slots and
events we can add
to each component so if i jump to style
then we have this size prop and we can
set this to
a pixel value or a rem value
or a generic name such as xs for extra
small
or md for medium so let's use this size
prop on our icon
i'm going to split the attributes on
this icon by using the
split html attributes extension which
you can get from the
extensions page in vs code i'm going to
add this
size prop and i'm going to set it to lg
for large
and if i save that our icon is now nice
and large
and i also want it to be our primary
color so i'll jump back to the
api section here and we have this color
prop
and we can just set it to any of the
colors which i showed you before on the
color palette page
we want to set it to our primary color
so i'm going to add this color prop
i'll just set that to primary and save
that
and the icon now has our primary color
okay let's add some padding around this
icon because it's currently squished up
into the corner
and if we go to the quasar site and
style on identity and spacing
then we have these really handy classes
that we can use to add
padding and margin to our elements and
we have some examples down below
so if we wanted to add a small amount of
padding in all directions we could just
add q
dash p for padding a for all directions
dash sm for small or if we just wanted
to add padding on the left we could add
q dash p l for padding left and then
dash
sm or dash lg so i'm just going to add a
medium amount of padding around this
icon so our icon is here so i'll add a
class
of q p for padding a for all directions
dash md for medium and i'll save that
and that's looking a lot better
and we also have equivalent classes for
margin so if we wanted to add margin all
around we would just change this p
to an m but i'm going to leave this as
padding
okay let's add some navigation items so
i'm going to jump back to the quasar
site
uh view components and list
and list items i'm going to scroll down
a bit
and i want our navigation items to look
something like this this top item here
with an icon on the left and some text
because this is what the
navigation links on twitter kind of look
like so
i'm going to click on view source here
and i'm just going to copy all of this
cue list component
i'm going to paste it under our icon
here i'll just fix
the indentation and i'll save that and
we now see
this list on the page so each of these
list items
is in a queue item component and i'm
only interested in this top
one here this one here so i'm just going
to remove all of the other
cue item components and also all of
these cue separators as well
so i'll get rid of all of those and save
that and we now just have this
one item and this list currently has a
border around it
and that's being added by this bordered
prop on the cue list so i'll get rid of
that prop
save that and we see the border
disappear and i'm going to change the
label on this item
to home because i'm going to make this a
link to our home page
so i'll change this text here icon as
avatar to
home save that and i want to change this
icon to a little house icon or something
so i'm going to jump to the material
icons page we opened before
search for home and this icon looks
pretty good so we just need to use the
class
home and if we look inside this cue item
here we have this
cue icon with the name set to bluetooth
so i'm just going to change that to home
and save that
and this is looking pretty good i just
want to increase the size of this icon a
little bit
so again i'll add a size prop uh let's
try setting this to medium so
md save that and that looks pretty good
and i also want to make this text here
big and bold
just like the navigation items on the
twitter site
so i'm going to jump back to the
typography page in style and identity
and typography
let's try this h6 class so we just need
to add a class of text
h6 to use this style so we'll add that
to this cue
item section here where our text is
so just add class text h6
and i'll save that and that's looking
pretty good and i also want it to be a
bit bolder
so we can just use the class we used
before text dash weight
dash bold save that and this is looking
pretty nice now
pretty similar to the twitter navigation
items
so i want this to link to our home page
so i'm going to jump back to
the list and list items component page
and jump down to the queue item api
and in this behavior section we can add
this to prop
to give our item a link so i'm going to
add that to
this cue item here i'm going to split
the attributes again
and add this to prop i'm just going to
set this to
forward slash which is the root of our
app the home page
so i'll save that and this should now
link to our home page
and the text has changed to blue because
this is now currently the active link
because we're on the home
page so let's duplicate this cue item
and create a link for our about page
which we're going to create later on
so i'm just going to duplicate this cue
item and i'll set the path
to slash about and i'll change the text
here
to about and save that
and i want to use a different icon here
so i'll jump to the material icons page
let's just search for help and we can
just use this icon here so we just need
to use the name help
so this cue icon here i'm going to
change the name to help
and save that and that's looking pretty
decent
and now that these queue items are links
because of this to prop
we should now be able to remove this
color prop from our icons and they
should be
colored automatically because i'd like
the icon to be black when it's not
currently the active link
just like the text is black when it's
not the current active link
so i'm going to remove both of these
color props from both of these
cue icons and save that and this
inactive icon now changes to black later
on when we create the about page and we
jump to
the about page we should see this icon
and this text changed to blue
and this home icon and text change to
black and finally let's make this draw a
little bit less wide because it's quite
a bit wider than
the left draw on the twitter site and if
we jump to the quasar site
and layout and grid
and layout draw and jump down to the
draw
api and then jump to style
then we have this width prop that we can
use to set the width
of the draw so let's add this to our
draw
i'm just going to split the attributes
on this q drawer
and add this with prop and this is
expecting a number not a string so i'm
going to bind to
this width prop by adding a colon
at the start and i'm going to set this
to 283
and i'll save that and our draw is now a
little bit narrower
[Music]
let's put some stuff in this right
drawer now because it's looking a little
bit sad so if you look at the twitter
site
over on the right here we have a search
bar and then a kind of a news feed
so let's add a search bar first so i'm
going to jump to the quasar site
view components and form components and
input text field
i'm going to scroll down
and i'd like something like this with an
icon over on the left
although we're going to use a search
icon so i'm going to click on
view source and just grab this first
queue input component copy that
and we'll paste it to the top of our
right drawer
and the right drawer is here this q draw
component
so i'll paste that q input there and
save that and i'm going to add a bit of
margin around this
so i'm going to split the attributes on
this q input
and i'll remove this v model because
we're not going to connect this to
anything and a lot of class
of q dash m a for margin all
dash md for medium we now have a little
bit of margin around it
and i would like this to be rounded and
outlined
instead of square and filled and if we
jump back to the quasar site
and jump down to the api section
and style scroll down a bit
so we have an outline prop we can use
for an outline design
and a rounded prop we can use to give
our input a bit of border radius
so i'm going to replace these filled and
square props
with outlined and rounded save that
and that's looking pretty good i'm going
to add a placeholder to this
which just says search quitter
save that and i'd like this to be a
little bit smaller
and if we jump back to the api then we
have this dense prop which we can use
which makes certain components a little
bit smaller so i'll add this dense prop
as well
and it's now a little bit smaller and we
need to replace this
icon and the icon is here so i'll change
this name to
search which is a material icon we can
use
and this is looking pretty good now so
let's add a little news feed here
so i'll jump back to the quasar site
and list and list items and i'll scroll
down and look for something that looks
like
a news feed so this looks pretty good
this top item here so i'm going to click
on view source
and i'll just copy this first queue item
and this opening
cue list tag and we'll paste that under
our input fix the indentation
we need to add the closing cue list tag
so i'll add that down here
save that and i don't want this border
on the list so let's remove this
bordered prop
uh let's change the text of these
headings here
this first line could be like a category
such as
politics so i'll change the text in
there to let's say
education and this second item i'll just
put some text in there something amazing
happened save that and i'd like this
education text to be
kind of a gray color like we see here
so a lot of class to this education
label
of text gray which is one of those
colors you can find on the color palette
page we looked at before
save that and i want this second heading
to be bold
so a lot of class to that as well of
text
weight dash bold same one we used before
okay this is looking pretty good so i'll
duplicate this cue item a couple of
times
so we have a few items save that
and i'd like to have a little line
between each item
and if we jump back to the list and list
items page and down to the cue list api
and style no it's in content actually
we have this separator prop we can use
to add a separator between
each item so we want to add that to the
cue list component
so i'll add that here separator
save that and we now see a little line
between each item
and i'd like to have a little bit more
padding within each of these
cue items so i'm going to select each of
these queue items
do a multiple selection and add a class
to each one
of q pa for padding all dash
md for medium and we now have a little
bit more space
within each of these items okay i'm
pretty happy with this layout for now
let's see how it looks on mobile i'll
scale this down
and yeah it's looking pretty good
however on the twitter mobile app
we actually see the twitter logo here at
the top in the middle
instead of some text here so let's do
the same thing on our app
so on desktop we'll see some text here
and on mobile we'll hide the text and
display
our logo at the top instead
[Music]
okay let's make this title here in our
header only appear on larger displays
and quasar has some responsive classes
that we can use
to show our hide different elements on
different
screen sizes so i'll jump to the quasar
site
and style an identity
and visibility and i'll scroll down to
window width related so in quasar we
have five different breakpoints
xs sm md lg and xl
and it tells you the width thresholds of
these
break points here and you can override
these default thresholds
and it tells you how to do that on this
sas scss
variables page well anyway we have some
classes that we can use with these break
points
so if we want something to only display
on extra small
windows then we can just add this xs
class to the element
and the same for all the other
breakpoints and if we scroll down a
little bit
says here you can also show some dom
element or component
if it's lower than one of these sizes
same for
greater than one of these sizes just
attach lt dash or gt
prefixes so if we use a class such as
lt-md
to an element then that element will
only be displayed on
windows which are smaller than the
medium breakpoint
so only on xs and sm screen sizes
so i'm going to jump back to our app
let's find this
title that's in our header so our q
header is here and here's our title
so i'm going to wrap this text in a span
and i'll add a class of gt-sm
i only want this text to appear if the
window is greater than the
small break point so in other words only
show this text on medium
large and extra large displays so i'll
save that
and if we scale down our browser then we
see that text disappear
scale it back up and it reappears again
okay so let's add our logo up here but
only on
mobile devices so i'm going to grab the
icon that's already in our left drawer
up here
and that icon is here so i'll copy that
and i'll paste it after this span
indent that i'll add a visibility class
here
so we only want to show this on screen
sizes that are less than medium
so i'm going to add lt-md and save that
and if we scale this down yeah we can
see that logo appear
scale it back up and it disappears again
so i'll just scale this back down again
i want this to be a little bit smaller
up here so this size prop i'm going to
set that to
sm for small and i also want this to be
in the center of the header
quasar does have some positioning
classes that we can use stretch this out
a bit if we go
to style and identity positioning
so we have classes such as this absolute
center class
which we could use so i'll just add that
to this icon
absolute dash center save that and this
looks great
here however for devices such as the
iphone 10
11 and 12 the header is actually a lot
taller than this
because it adds extra space for the
notches on those devices
and if we use this class it will also
put this icon in the vertical center as
well
so it ends up being up in the middle of
the
header somewhere up here so instead of
using this class
i'm gonna add a custom class to this
icon
we could call it header dash icon
and we'll just add some custom css to
put this in the center
so i'm going to jump down to the bottom
of this file
and add a style section with the line
set to sas
and we'll target this header icon class
and i'm going to set the position to
absolute
i'm going to set the bottom to zero
to put it right at the bottom then i'm
going to set the left to
50 percent and then to pull it back
into the center i'm going to use
transform
and i'm going to set translate x to
minus 50
and save that and the icon is now in the
middle
so we now have a different header for
mobile
and desktop okay so i'm pretty happy
with this layout now so we're almost
ready to start working on our pages
but before we do that let's set up some
pages and routes
[Music]
let's set up some pages and routes for
our home
and about pages because right now if we
look at our
two items in our left draw here this
home item is linking to the path
slash which is working well this about
item is linking to the path
slash about and we haven't set up a
route for that yet so if we click on
about we just get this
error page which by the way is just this
error 404.view file in the pages folder
and this isn't much fun and first of all
i'm just going to open up this page we
see here
which is in source pages index.view
and i'm going to remove these flex
classes here because i don't want
everything to be in the center
on this page and then i'm just going to
remove this image as well
and for now i'm just going to put h5 in
here which says home
and i'll change the name of this
component as well to
page home to make it a bit more clear
what this is
and i'll save that and i'll also rename
this page
so i'll change it from index.view to
pagehome.view to make it a bit more
clear what it is
and this now breaks our app because if
we go to our roots
file in source router roots.js
we can see our root here and it's
currently looking for a component called
index.view so we need to change this to
page
home.view because we just renamed it
save that
and that's now working again and let's
duplicate this route
and set up a route for our about page so
the path
is going to be slash about uh let's
point this to a page called
pageabout.view so i'll change this to
page
about.view and save that and this breaks
our app again because this page doesn't
exist yet
so i'm going to duplicate pagehome.view
and if you don't see this option here
this duplicate file or directory option
this is being added by the duplicate
action extension which you can find in
the extension store
and i'm going to duplicate this and call
it page
about dot view
i'll open that up and change the text in
here to about
and i'll change the component name to
page about and save that
let's see if this is working yep we can
now navigate between both of our pages
however we have a little issue with our
active classes
on these navigation items here when
we're on the home page
the home link is active which is okay
but if we jump to the about page
the about link becomes active but the
home link stays
active as well and we can't fix this if
we go to the quasar site
view components and list and list items
and jump down to the queue item api then
we have this
exact prop which we can add to our queue
items
which is an equivalent to view routers
exact property
which means that the active classes will
only be added to these
links when we're on the exact route that
they
refer to so i'll jump to main
layout.view
and add this exact prop to both of these
queue items
and i'll save that and this seems to be
fixed now
okay our pages are set up however on the
twitter site
if we look at the header it doesn't
actually display twitter up here
it displays the name of the current page
so if we're on the homepage it says home
and if we're on the notifications page
it says
notifications so let's do the same thing
here
instead of displaying quitter and what
we can do is we can jump to our roots
file
and in fact i'm just going to split this
up onto multiple lines
so it doesn't get too messy and what we
can do is add a name property
to each of these like this
and we can set the homepage route to
home
on the about page root we can set this
name property to about
i'll save that and we can now access
these properties
anywhere within our app by using the
dollar root object
so if we now jump to main layout.view
and our header
which is here and here's where we're
spitting out that quitter
text what we can do is replace this with
double curly braces
and then dollar root and then doc name
so i'll save that and we now see home in
the header and if we jump to the about
page
we see about okay so we're ready to
start working on our pages now
uh let's work on the about page first
because this is going to be
nice and easy
[Music]
okay let's set up our about page so we
want to go to source pages and page
about.view
i'm just going to add a heading and some
text so i'm going to get rid of this h5
and i'm going to add a h4 with the text
about
quitter and then i'm just going to add a
paragraph
with some lorem ipsum and i'll duplicate
that paragraph so we've got two
and we could do is some padding on this
page
so we can use the same classes we used
before so i'll add a class to the q
page component and set this to q
p a dash l g so we have a large padding
on this page
i'm going to remove the top margin from
this heading because we have quite a lot
of space up here
so this h4 i'll add a class of
q mt for margin top dash none
for zero margin and i'll also reduce the
bottom margin a little bit
so i'll add a class of q dash m b for
margin bottom
dash md for medium and i also want this
heading to
be bold so i'll add a class of text dash
weight dash
bold save that and i'd like this
paragraph text to be a little bit bigger
so i'm going to jump to the quasar site
and
style an identity and typography and
this text
body one class should do the job so i'll
copy that class
and i'll surround these paragraphs in a
div with that class
and i'll just move those in there and
save that okay this is looking pretty
good we're now ready to
start working on our homepage and start
adding the real guts of our app
[Music]
let's start working on our home page so
we need some kind of input at the top
here where we can add a tweet
and if we look at the twitter site we
have an input here with a placeholder
that says what's happening
we have an avatar over on the left and
we have a character counter thing which
stops us
typing too many characters and we have a
submit button here as well
so let's see if we can find something
similar on the quasar site
so i'm going to go to view components
form components and input text field
and i'm going to scroll down and see if
i can find something nice
so this is kind of what we want this
input has an avatar on the left
it has a character counter here which
stops us typing too many characters
and it has a submit button over on the
right here so this is
number one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten the tenth one down
so i'll click on
view source and grab the tenth one down
so one two three four five six seven
eight nine and ten
so i'll grab this q input here copy that
and paste it to the top of our home page
which is in source pages page home.view
and i'll just paste it over this h5
fix the indentation and save that we
could do with a bit of space around this
so i'm going to surround this cue input
in a div and i'll add some padding
classes to this
and we can actually specify vertical
padding and
horizontal padding independently so i'd
like quite a lot of vertical padding
and a little bit less horizontal padding
and so to add vertical padding we can
just add q
dash p for padding and then y for
padding on the y
axis then a dash and then i'll add lg
for large
save that and we need to put this q
input inside that div
so i'll just move that up save that and
then to add some padding on the x axis
i'll add q dash p x for padding on the x
axis dash md for a medium padding save
that
let's customize this input a little bit
i'm going to split the attributes on
this q
input i'm going to remove this dense
prop and i'll set this label to
what's happening like on the twitter
site
and if we use this label prop then when
we click into the field
we see the label pop up to the top there
but i prefer using a placeholder where
the
text just disappears when you click into
the field so i'll change this label to a
placeholder
save that and that text now disappears
um we want the maximum length of this
field to be 280 characters and not 12.
so i'll set this max length to 280 and
save that
and we can see that update there let's
see if that's working
i'll just paste loads of text in there
and that doesn't seem to be working and
that's because we need to bind this to a
data property
so this v model here i'll change this to
new quit
content and i'll set up a data property
for that
so in our script section i'll add our
data method
that returns an object and add this
property new
tweet content and i'll just set it to an
empty string
and save that let's see if this
character counter is working now
yeah we can see the characters counting
up and when we get to 280 it stops us
from typing anymore
and i'll remove this clear button on
this clock button which is in this
template tag here so i'll get rid of
that i'll get rid of this
field hint slot as well
save that and i'm going to replace this
avatar image with
my image and that's this image tag here
and i have the link in my clipboard but
you can use
your own avatar if you want i'll save
that
and i want to increase the size of this
avatar and this cute avatar component
like the q icon component has a size
prop that we can use
so i'll set the size to excel for extra
large
and i'm going to replace this submit
button here with a text
style button like this one here so i'll
jump to
quasar site view components buttons
button scroll down and i'd like
something like this
a rounded solid button and this is on
the fourth line so i'll click on view
source
so one two three four and i think it's
this one here
with the rounded prop so i'll copy that
paste it over this send button here and
save that
let's customize this button i'm going to
split the attributes on that
and change the label to quit
save that and i don't want the text on
this button to be capitalized and if we
jump back to the button page and the api
section
and style maybe i'll scroll down
no it's not in there maybe general
maybe content we have this no caps prop
that we can use
to disable those uppercase characters
so i'll add that prop to this q button
no caps
and if we look at the twitter site if we
have nothing in this field
then this button is disabled so let's do
the same thing with r button
and if we jump back to the button page
and
behavior or maybe it's general
no maybe style or it could be in state
we have this disable prop that we can
use to disable a
button so we'll bind to the disable
prop and we want to disable this button
if there's nothing in this
new quick content property so we can
just set this disable prop to
not new quick content and save that
and the button is now disabled but if we
type something it's now
enabled again now i want this input to
automatically grow vertically as we add
more content
because right now it just goes from left
to right like that
but if we look at the twitter site we
can actually add new lines here
and the input keeps on growing so i'm
going to jump back to the quasar site
and back to
form components and input text field
jump down to the queue input api
and if we jump to the content section
and scroll down
we have this auto grow prop which will
make this field
grow automatically so let's add this
prop as well
auto grow save that and now if we add
tons of content in here it's not working
because i added it to
the button instead of this input so i'll
cut that auto grow prop
uh we'll add it to this q input instead
save that
let's try that again
yep it's now auto growing and all the
content is added to
new lines and i'd like the font size in
this input to be quite a bit bigger i'm
actually zoomed out of the twitter page
here but if i set the zoom to normal
then you can see the text in this field
is quite a lot bigger
and unfortunately there's no size prop
or text size prop
available for the queue input so what
we'll do
is add a class to our queue input and
add some
custom styles so i'll add a class to
this q
input of new dash quit save that
jump down to the style section which
doesn't exist yet
so we'll add that style with sass and
we'll target this new
quit class we'll set the font size
to the same as it is on the twitter page
which i think is 19 pixels
and save that and the text is now nice
and big
however we could do with a bit more line
height here so allow the line height
property as well
and set that to 1.4 that doesn't seem to
be working let's try adding important
save that just reload the page
and that line height is still not
working i'm just going to inspect this
let's drag this out a bit and i'll just
drag this down
so our class is being added on this
label element here you can see it there
new quick
but we're trying to style this text area
and the line height writing
isn't cascading down so let's make this
more specific instead of just targeting
this new quick class
we'll target the text area within that
so i'll add text area
and indent these styles close the
inspector and see if that works
yeah it seems to have worked i'll just
reload that
yeah we now have a nice amount of line
height on this field
so as this input grows down vertically
this quick button stays right up here
and i think it'd be better if it stayed
docked down here next to the bottom of
this
input and quasar has a grid system that
we can use to have more control
over how things are laid out so if we go
to the quasar site
then layout and grid then flex grid and
introduction to
flexbox then it tells us all about this
grid system that we can use and if we
jump to grid row
so we can set up rows with columns
inside
and if i just click on view source to
create a row we can just
use the class row and then inside that
we can add some divs
with a class of call to create columns
so what we could do is put all of this
inside
a row and then put the input and the
avatar
in a column inside the row and then put
the button
inside another column because when we
use the grid system and these rows and
columns we have more control over the
positions of things within the
columns so for example we can tell
everything to force itself down to the
bottom of the column
so i'm going to jump to this input and
we already have a div
around this input so we could just make
this a row by adding a class of row
and i'll save that and then inside this
row i'm going to add two columns so i'll
add a div with the class of call
and then another div with a class of
call i'll just break these up
i'm going to select the input and cut
that
and paste it inside this first column
and then our button which is currently
in this after slot i'll cut that and get
rid of this
slot and paste this button in this
second column
let's fix the indentation
and save that i'll just reload the page
and currently these columns are 50 50
they're both the same width because by
default columns will just take up
an equal amount of space so if there's
two columns they take up 50
each or if there are three columns they
take up a third of the available width
but we can add a class to this second
column
to force it to shrink so we can just add
a class of call
dash shrink and all of these classes are
explained
in this flex grid section on the quasar
site
so we'll save that and this column is
now shrinking
but we still want this button to be
pushed down to the bottom
of the column and if we jump back to
this grid row page
and scroll down to alignment
there's some classes we can use here so
for vertical alignment
we can use this items end class on the
row
to force the content of the columns down
to the bottom of the column
so let's add this items n class to our
row
so our row is here so we'll just add
items
dash end and save that
and this button is now right at the
bottom however this button is now
touching the input and we need a bit of
space between these columns
so we need a gutter so if we jump back
to the quasar site
and grid gutter and if we scroll down
we can use these cue call gutter classes
to add a gutter between our columns
so we just need to add a class to the
row such as cue call gutter sm
so i'll copy this class we'll add it to
our row here and i'll save that and i'd
like a little bit more space than that
so i'll change this to
cue call gutter dash md for medium
and that's looking pretty good now and
this button is a little bit too low down
at the moment i'd like it to be
sort of in line with this line here so
i'm just gonna add a bit of bottom
margin to that button
so a lot of class to this button of
q dash and b for margin bottom dash
let's try md save that maybe a little
bit more
i'll change this to lg and yeah that
looks pretty good
let's see if it follows the input down
the page
and yeah it does so i think that's much
better now
and there's one more thing i want to do
here if we look at the twitter site
after this input section we have this
little divider here
with a gray background and a little gray
top and bottom border
so let's add something similar under our
input
maybe we could use the q separator
component so i'm going to jump to the
quasar site and then
view components and separator
scroll down and by default this is just
a single line
but maybe we can customize it a little
bit so i'm just going to click on view
source
and grab one of these cue separators
and we'll paste it after our div with
the row class
so i'll paste that here and save that
right now it's just a single line not
quite like the twitter one
but if we jump to the separator api
and style then we have a size prop we
can use to set the thickness of it
in pixels or rems so i'll add a size
prop to this
cue separator and i think the one on
twitter is about 10 pixels so i'll set
this to
10 pixels and that's looking pretty good
however it's a little bit dark compared
to this twitter one
and if we jump back to the api section
we also have a color prop we can use to
set the color
so i'll add that as well and then i'm
going to jump to the color palette page
so styling identity and color palette uh
let's look for some grays
uh maybe this gray two color will work
so i'll set this color prop to
gray dash two i'll save that
um we're almost there with this
separator but the one on twitter has
these little
top and bottom borders and i don't think
there's a
border prop for the cue separator so
what we can do
is add a class to this in fact i'll
split the attributes here
add a class of let's say divider
we'll add some custom css to add a top
and bottom border
so we'll target this divider class and
i'll set the border
top to one pixel solid and the border
bottom to one pixel solid and then we'll
set the border color
and if i jump back to the color palette
page
maybe we could use a darker color here
because we can actually use these colors
in our css because we have css variables
for all of these colors
so maybe something like gray-5 so what
we can do here is set this border color
to dollar
and then gray dash five and i'll save
that
and they look a little bit too dark
let's try gray four
so i'll change this to grade four and
yeah that's looking pretty decent now
okay so i think we're done with our new
quit form let's move on to our list of
quiz
[Music]
let's add a list of tweets down here and
tweets
have the avatar over on the left then
they have the user's name and then the
handle
and then the date the tweet was posted
and then we have the tweet underneath
and some buttons underneath that so
let's see if we can find something we
can use
on the quasar site so i'll go to list
and list items
and i'm going to jump down to more
involved examples
and scroll down a bit and these email
list items
look pretty good we've got the avatar
title at the top
and then a time over on the right so
i'll click on view source
and i'll just copy all of this cue list
and
paste it after our cue separator and
i'll get rid of all except the first
queue item so i'll get rid of this cue
separator
and this cue item here and save that
and let's customize this a bit so i'll
split the attributes on the cue list
i'll remove this style property which is
restricting the width
and i'll remove this rounded borders
class
and i'll remove this bordered prop as
well
and i'll remove this friends label at
the top
and i'll replace this avatar with the
avatar that's
next to our input so i'll scroll up
and grab this q avatar copy that and
paste it over this
q avatar save that
and these lines props on these labels
here are restricting the number of lines
that can be displayed
and i don't want this to be restricted
so i'll remove this lines prop
from both of these cue item labels
and i'll remove this caption prop which
i think is making the text
a bit smaller and i'll change the text
in here so i'll put
my name in here this first cue item
label
and i'll just split this up actually
i'll save that
and i want this to be bold so i'll wrap
this
in a strong tag and i want to display
my handle next to this in gray so i'll
add a spam
and i'll use one of quasars color
classes i'm going to use
text gray dash 7 and i'll put my handle
in there
save that and on the queue item here
this clickable prop and this be
ripple prop uh making this clickable
um adding this ripple effect and i don't
want those so i'll remove these props
and i think we need a bit more vertical
padding on these
items so a lot of class to this cue item
of q dash p y dash
md save that and i'll replace the text
in this
second cue item label where our tweet is
going to go
so i'll just select everything inside
this cue item label and
put some laura mipsum and we want to
make sure this can handle
new lines so i'll stick a new line in
here
and save that and we can't see the new
lines being added
so what i'm going to do i'll add a class
to this queue item label
of queat content
we'll add some css at the bottom so
we'll target the queet
content class and to make sure those new
lines are preserved
and shown we can just set the white
space
property to pre dash line save that
and we can now see those lines and this
avatar is currently
vertically centered but i want it to be
always at the top
and if we scroll up here this q avatar
is inside
a q item section so let's see if we can
find the
api for that and it's down here cue item
section api
so i'll jump to that and we have this
top prop that we can add which will
align content to the top so we'll add
that to
this cue item section here save that and
i want the text to be a little bit
bigger
both here at the top and the content
text as well
so i'm going to jump to the typography
page so styling identity typography
maybe we could use this subtitle one on
the heading
of the tweet so text subtitle one
so i'll add that to this first cue item
label
with the username and handle in it
so text dash subtitle one save that
and i want this body text to be a bit
bigger as well
so maybe we could use this body one
style
with the class text dash body one so
i'll add that class to
the second cue item label text dash body
one
save that and this is looking pretty
good now pretty similar to
the way tweets appear on twitter and now
we just need this action bar at the
bottom with some buttons
uh let's add these to the bottom of this
cue item section underneath our
tweet so after this q item label
i'll add a row and we'll stick some
buttons in here
so i'll jump to the quasar site go to
view components buttons button
and scroll down and we just want some
icon buttons
something like this a bit like these
buttons on
twitter
so i'll grab the code for that which is
this one here
copy that paste it into this row
and i'll split the attributes and save
that
and i don't want this to be blue i want
it to be gray
so i'm going to change this color prop
to gray save that
i want it to be a bit smaller so i'll
add a size prop as well
set that to sm for small and i want to
use some font awesome
icons here so i'll jump to the font
awesome page
and i'm going to search for comment
because we'll add a button for comments
and this one looks pretty good so i'll
click on that
and copy this example here
i'll just paste it after this q button
for now
so i'll replace this icon prop here with
these classes here
so i'll copy that paste that in there
i'll get rid of this save that uh let's
add three more buttons so i'll duplicate
this
three times i'm going to use some other
font awesome buttons which i found on
the font awesome page here
so i'm going to use a retweet icon with
the classes fas
and then fa retweet and then i'm going
to use the heart icon with the classes
f a r and then f a dash heart
and then i'm going to use a delete icon
with the classes f
a s f a dash trash save that
and we can see all of those icons
and i want these icons to spread out and
there's a bunch of
flex classes we can use and they're all
on the
flex pages on the quasar site
so i'm going to add a class to this row
with our buttons
of justify between to add
space between all of our items here and
i'll also add a top margin to this
button to make a bit of space
at the top so i'll add q mt
sm save that and lastly i just want to
nudge these icons
back over to the left a bit because if
you look at the twitter
tweets this left icon aligns perfectly
with the
text over on the left
so i'm going to add a class to this row
of queet
icons and then in the style section
we'll target this class quite icons
and we'll add a negative left margin so
i'll set margin
left to minus 5 pixels save that
and this icon is now lined up with this
text
okay i'm pretty happy with the design of
this tweet now
[Music]
let's set up some data for our quiz so
i'm going to jump down to the data
section
and i'm going to add an array called
queets
and we'll stick each queen inside an
object
so we'll add a content property and i'll
just put some
lorem ipsum in there and we'll add a
date property
and i'm just going to use the timestamp
format for this
so i'm going to jump to the console in
chrome just run date.now
to get the current date i'll copy that
and paste that here
i'll duplicate this object and just
change the date
so i'll just run date dot now again copy
this date
uh paste that in there i'll save that
and we'll spit these out on the page
using a v4 loop so i'll jump up to
this quee which is here this q item
i'll split the attributes and add a v4
and we want to loop through this quits
array
so i'll do v4 quit in
quits and we also need a key property
and for now i'm just going to use the
date as a key
although later on when we set up
firebase we will add some ids
to our quits which we'll also use as the
key later on
but for now i'm just going to set the
key to quit
date and save that
and we now see two quits on the page so
let's hook up the content and the
date so i'm going to select everything
inside this cue item label
and instead output quet
dot content and save that
i'll do the same for the date which is
here
so double curly braces and quits
dot date and i'll save that and i want
to have a separator between each tweet
so we can use the
separator prop on the cue list which we
used
over here so i'll add separator
and save that and this date doesn't look
too hot so let's format this using the
date
fns package so i'm going to search for
date fns
in fact i'm just going to go straight to
date fns.org
i'm going to jump to documentation and
getting started
and i'll jump down to installation so we
can install this with
npm install date fns so i'm going to
copy that
jump to my terminal and kill the dev
process
and just run that command and that's
installed so i'm going to launch the dev
process again with quasar dev
and that's running again so i'm going to
jump back to date fns
and if we look down at the bottom here
we can use this format distance method
to output a date in a relative format
such as
three days ago like this so i'm going to
copy this import line
and add it to the top of our script
section
so i'll paste that here and we don't
need this
sub days method so i'll get rid of that
let's set up a filter
which will use this method to format the
date
so it's going to collapse the data
object
out of filters object and we'll create a
filter called
relative date and this is going to
expect a value
and we need to return a value so i'm
just going to copy this line from this
example i'll paste that there and i'll
just stretch this out a sec
so this is going to expect two dates two
parameters
and it's going to return the distance
between those two dates
in a relative form such as three days
ago
so in the second parameter here we have
the current date
and this first parameter we want to pass
in our date
so i'm going to replace all of this with
value and save that
and now let's use this filter on our
date here so
i want to scroll up to our date which is
here
and then just add a pipe and the name of
our filter
relative date save that and we can now
see some nice relative dates here
after the user types in some text here
and clicks on the quit button
then we want to add the new quick to our
quits array so that it's displayed here
so i'm going to add a click handler to
this quick button which is here
so i'll add a click and we'll trigger a
method called
add new quit i'll jump down to the
script section and add a methods object
and add this method
add new quit and for now i'll just log
out
add new quee and make sure that
click handler is working so i'll clear
the console
click on the button and we see that
being logged out so what do we want to
do here
well we want to set up an object such as
this
and we want to set the content to the
content that the user entered
and we want to set the date to the
current date then we just want to push
that object to this quits array so we'll
set up that object first
so we'll call this new quet
set that equal to an object and we need
a content property
which we're going to grab from this new
quick content
property which is hooked up to this
input
so we'll set this to this dot new quick
content
and then we need a date property with
the current date so we can just fire
date dot now
to get that and now we just want to push
this quick to our
array of quits so we can just do
this.quits
dot push and then pass in this you quit
object
save that let's see if that's working
and it's worked it's added our quick to
the list
and the relative date is working however
this is right at the bottom
and really we want our new quits to be
at the top
so instead of pushing it to the quakes
array we'll unshift it instead
so i'll just change push to on shift
save that and reload
let's try that again
and yeah that's working how we want it
to now
[Music]
let's add the ability to delete a tweet
when someone clicks on one of these
delete buttons
so i'll add a click handler to this
button so
i'll scroll up to these buttons and this
is
the delete button so we'll add a click
and we'll trigger a method called delete
queet
and we'll just pass in the whole of the
quit object
so i'll pass quit in here and we'll set
up this method
so i'll add that here so delete queet
pass in the quit object and for now
we'll just log out
this quit object and i'll just change
this
string here to delete queet and save
that
and i'll open up the console
uh click on one of these delete buttons
um we can see that log being fired and
we can see the data
from the queen whose delete button was
clicked so now we just want to remove
the correct
quet from our quits array and i'm just
going to do this based on the
date for now although later on when we
set up firebase we'll do all this stuff
based on ids
instead but in this deletequick method
i'm just going to grab the
date to delete from this quit so i'll
put this in a variable
called date to delete
so quite date so we want to delete the
quit in the array which has this date
here
which will be in this variable so we
could use the find index method
to find the index the position of the q
in the array which has this date
so we can do let's index and then we can
do this.quits
dot find index and this is going to loop
through each item
in our array so we need a placeholder
and i'll just use quit as a placeholder
then we want to fire a method with our
criteria
i'm just going to stretch this out a bit
and we just want to see if quite
date is equal to this date here
so equal to date to delete
and that should give us the index of the
tweet that we want to delete
so i'll just log out the index for now
save that
so click on this first delete button and
yeah we see index zero
click on the next one you see index one
so now we just want to remove
the item in the array at the position of
this index
so we can now just do this dot quits
dot splice
and pass in the index as the first
parameter and then just pass in one as
the second parameter
so that we only delete one item uh i'll
just remove these
console logs and save that now let's see
if it's working
i'll just reload click on delete
and yeah it seems to be working and just
to make sure it's deleting the right
quits because these are both identical
i'm just going to put some different
text in one of these tweaks
and i have this little chrome extension
called quotes
which will generate a quote so
i'm just going to use that just so i
don't have to keep typing loads of
tweets i'll just paste that in here and
i'll just get rid of that single quote
and save that okay so i'll try and
delete this one
yeah it seems to be deleting the correct
tweet if you found this video useful so
far
make sure you smash the like button and
leave a comment telling us what you
think about quasar
[Music]
let's add some nice animations for when
our tweets
disappear or appear in our list here
before we do that i just realized that
after we add a quick this input remains
populated
with whatever we just typed so i'm just
going to quickly fix that
so what we can do in this add new quick
method at the end
is just set this new quick content
property
which is bound to this input back to an
empty string
so we can just do this dot new quick
content equals
empty string save that let's try that
again
yep the field is now cleared okay back
to animations
uh quasar has a built-in animation
helper
which makes it really easy for us to add
animations to our elements and
components
when they appear or disappear on the
page so i want to jump to the quasar
site
and we want to go to quasar options and
helpers
and animations so we can use any of the
animations from animate.css
so i'm just going to click this link and
open that so we have all of these
different animations we can use
and i'm just going to use a nice and
simple fade in
and fade out animation but feel free to
use some of the more fancy animations if
you want
and we do need to note these class names
here fade in and fade out
because if we jump back to this
animations page on quasar
we do need to add these animations to
our quasar.conf
dot js file to this animations array
like this so i'm just going to open up
the quasar config file quasar.com.js
and i'll search for animations
i'm just going to add fade in and fade
out
to this array and save that
and if we scroll down here it shows us
how to use these
so if you want to add an animation to a
single component
such as a button then we can just
surround it in a
transition element with these props
and replace this fade in and fade out
with
whichever animation that we want to use
but if we want to wrap multiple elements
which we're going to do because we're
going to be doing this on a list which
is being split
out with a v4 loop then we want to use
this transition group
component instead so i'm just going to
copy the opening tag of this
transition group component jump back to
page home
dot view and find our quits
this is the queue item here and i'll
just collapse that
so we want to surround this in this
transition group component
so i'll paste the opening tag here and
indent that
and then i'll add the closing tag at the
bottom
and i'll just indent the cue item and
save that
and we don't need to change these
classes here because i am using the fade
in
and fade out animations but if you're
using a different animation then you
need to
update these so let's see if that's
working
i'll just reload the page and add a new
quit
and yeah it did have a brief fade in
animation there and if we delete one
we do see it fade out and i'd like to
slow this down a little bit
and so what we can do is just add
another class
to each of these props here of slow
and you can also use slower as well well
that's a bit too slow so i'm just going
to use
slow and this should slow down the
animation a little bit
so i'll add a new tweet here and i'm
just going to start using this
quote generator thing and yeah i think
that's a little bit nicer
and if we delete it yeah it's looking
pretty good and we do have an issue now
with our quits
can you tell what it is we've lost our
separator
between each of our tweets so why has
that happened
well if we just inspect our cue items
here
and have a look at what's going on
here's our cue list
and here's our queue item and the reason
we've lost that separator
is because adding this transition group
component
has added this span around all of our
cue items
so if i just temporarily comment out
this transition group
both the opening and closing tags and
save that
now we see the separator again and that
span that we saw has disappeared
so if i click on a cue item and take a
look at the styles
actually i don't think there's a
separator on the first queue item so
i'll look at the
second cue item and we can see the style
here which is adding that border
and the reason we lose the style when we
add that transition group
which adds that span is because this
selector is looking for
direct children of the containing
component
so what i'm going to do is copy this
border top property here
and put this transition group back in
then i'm going to add a class
to our queue item of queet
and we'll just set up some custom css to
put the separator back in
so i'll scroll down to the style section
and i'll add that here
so we'll target the quit class
and i'll paste in that style rule and
get rid of the
semicolon because you don't need that in
sas save that
and we can now see the separator again
however it's also added it to the
first quit as well which is making this
line
at the bottom of the divider thing look
a bit too thick
so what we can do is change this
selector here
and add a not selector to it so that it
ignores the first child
so the first cue item within the cue
list
so we can just add colon not
then parentheses and then colon first
child
and if we save that we now see the
separator disappear from the first child
but we'll still see it on all of the
tweaks which are below
the first child
[Music]
okay we're almost done with the front
end for this app but there's a couple of
final design tweaks
i want to make and the first one is i
don't like the fact that this column
with our relative date is squishing the
tweet content over here and also this
column is changing width
depending on the text so if we scroll
down to this one with two minutes
the column is a lot less wide and also
these icons
are sometimes right over here and
sometimes over here
so instead i'm going to move this
relative date
next to the handle which is how it looks
on
twitter anyway so we just have the name
the handle
a bullet and then the relative date and
the other thing is
i don't like the fact that when we have
a long list of quits and we scroll down
this left draw disappears
like that i think it would be better if
these navigation links stayed up here
which is how it works on the twitter
site if we scroll down
all of this stuff stays in place so
let's do the same thing on our app so
let's start by moving this
relative date next to this handle
so i'm going to jump to our cue item
with the queet and our relative date is
here
so i'm going to cut that and get rid of
this cue item section
and scroll up to our handle and i'll add
a space after that and then a new line
then i'll add a bullet by using and b u
l
l and semicolon and then we'll just spit
out the relative date there
so i'll save that and that's looking a
lot better
i'll just add a load of new creates and
yeah that's looking a lot better now
and let's see if it looks okay on mobile
so this relative date is sometimes being
spread across
multiple lines so what might do is just
add a break tag
before this relative date that only gets
added on mobile
so that this relative date gets pushed
down to the next line
so what i'll do is add a break tag here
um we only want this break tag to be
displayed on devices which are less than
medium
so i'm going to add a class of lt-md
and save that and on mobile we see the
relative date
is pushed down to a new line
but on desktop we see it side by side
with
the name and the handle okay now let's
fix this issue
of the left draw scrolling up the page
when we
scroll down a longer list of quits and
quasar has
a scroll area component which we can use
to make
a particular part of our app scrollable
so what we could do is put everything in
our home page
within a scroll area so that when we
scroll down our list of quits
we're just scrolling down the scroll
area that's surrounding everything on
the home page
so i'm going to jump to the quasar site
and a few components
and scroll area we see a basic scroll
area here
so i'm going to click on view source uh
i'll just copy the
opening tag for this cue scroll area
component
and i'll place that at the top of our q
page
just here i'm just going to collapse
everything else for now
and put the closing tag at the bottom
here
and then just indent everything save
that
and this is working except this scroll
area is currently way too small
and we do need to specify the width and
height of these
scroll area components in order for them
to work
so what we could do is make our page our
q page
component relatively positioned then we
could make this
scroll area component absolutely
positioned and set its width and height
to 100
so it fills up all of the available
space on our page
and quasar has some positioning classes
we can use to do this so i'm going to
jump to the quasar
site and then style and identity
and positioning so we can use this
relative position class to make an
element
relatively positioned so let's add that
to our q page
so class relative
dash position save that and then to make
this
q scroll area component absolutely
position
we can use this absolute class so i'm
going to remove this
style attribute here and add a class
of absolute and we also want to give
this
component 100 width and 100 height uh
maybe we could use this full screen
class for that which says
fixed position covering all window real
estate
so i'll add that class as well to the
cue scroll area
and save that let's see how that's
looking
and yeah it's looking pretty good so now
when we scroll down our tweets
we only scroll down this scroll area and
everything in our layout is
staying fixed in place let's just make
sure it looks okay on mobile
yeah looks okay
okay so i think we're done with all of
the front end for our app
let's set up a simple real-time back-end
for our app
using a firebase cloud firestore
database
[Music]
let's set up a firebase cloud firestore
database
to store all of our quit data and give
us real-time data sync
across all of our devices and everything
we're going to be using here from
firebase
is going to be free for reasonable
amounts of use
but just bear in mind that if you create
an app with a firebase database
and millions of people download it then
you will be expected to
start paying so you might want to check
out the pricing page at
firebase.google.com
pricing where you can see all of the
limits that are available on the free
plan
and then you just want to go to
firebase.google.com
and click on go to console and if you've
not already signed up it'll probably ask
you to sign up and sign in with your
google account
but i'm just going to click on go to
console and then i'm just going to click
on add project
and we need to enter a name and i'll
call it quitter
click on continue i'm going to disable
google analytics i'll click on create
project
it's finished creating the project so
i'm going to click on continue
and we're going to be creating a cloud
firestore database so i'm going to click
on
cloud firestore on the left here click
on create database
and i'm going to click on start in test
mode
just to make it easy for us to start
working with our database
but just bear in mind that anybody with
your database reference
will be able to view edit and delete
data in your database
when you have it set to test mode and
i'll click on next
and then it asks us to choose a location
i'm not sure what difference this makes
but i'm just going to click on enable
okay it's created our database and we
can see it here
and it's empty right now and cloud
firestore databases are made up of
collections
and collections contain documents and
each document is basically just a
javascript style
object so let's start a collection for
our quits
so i'm going to click on start
collection and i'm going to call this
quits
click on next and it's asking us to
add our first document and each document
needs to have an id
so i'm just going to click on auto id so
that firebase will generate an id for us
let's add a quick here and our quets
have a content field
and a date field so let's add a content
field
and i'm just going to use that quotes
extension to
paste in a quote here and then i'm going
to click on add field
and add a date field and this is going
to be a number
i'm just going to use date dot now in
the console to generate a date for us
so date dot now
then i'm going to copy this
paste that in here and click on save
so we can see our quits collection here
and all of our documents will be
displayed here
and this is the document id here and if
we click on that we can see
all of the fields in that document so
let's add a few more i'm going to click
on add document
click on auto id and add a content
field and again i'm just going to use
this little extension
click on add field and we'll set a date
set it to type number and again i'll
just use
the console to generate
a timestamp copy that
paste it in here click save and we'll
add another document
auto id content
and i'll paste in some content
add a date field set it to number
and again grab the current
date with date dot now and actually for
this one i'm gonna
set this date to an hour ago so we can
make sure uh ordering and stuff like
that is working
and there are three million six hundred
thousand milliseconds
in an hour so i'm just gonna copy this
and do that timestamp minus
three million six hundred thousand
and i'll copy this timestamp
and add it here and i'll just add one
more document
add the date
and grab the current timestamp date.now
paste that in there click save okay so
we now have a decent amount of data in
our database
but to get access to our database we
need to set up an
app so i'm just going to stretch this
out
and open up this sidebar we want to go
to project overview
and here's where we can add it up we
want to add a web app so i'm going to
click on this
web icon give it a name i'm just going
to give it the same name
quitter and click on register app
and it tells us how to initialize our
database with
some script tags but i'm not going to do
it this way because the correct
way to initialize a package like this in
quasar
is to import the modules we need and use
a boot file so i'm going to leave this
open though because we're going to need
this
config object later on but i'm just
going to click on this
get started link down here and open that
in a new tab
and it tells us how to get started here
i'm going to scroll down
so we've already created a firebase
project and we've already registered our
app with firebase
so step three add firebase sdks and
initialize firebase
we want to click on using module
bundlers here
and so first of all we need to install
firebase to our project
so i'm going to copy this and jump to
our terminal
kill the dev process and run that
command to install firebase
okay that's finished installing we jump
back to this firebase page
it tells us how to initialize firebase
with these two
code samples here and we're going to add
these to a boot file
and again a boot file allows us to run
code
before our app starts so i'm going to
jump to the quasar site
on quasar cli and boot files
and i'll jump down to when to use boot
files so boot files
fulfill one special purpose they run
code before the apps
view root component is instantiated
while giving you access to certain
variables
which is required if you need to
initialize a library interfere with view
router
inject view prototype or inject the root
instance of the view app
we don't need to do anything with view
router or the view prototype or anything
but we do want to initialize our
connection to firebase before our app
starts
so that we have immediate access to our
database when our app is ready and if we
scroll down to
usage of boot files it shows us how to
generate a boot file we can just run
quasar new boot and then the name
so i'm going to jump back to the
terminal and run quasar
new boots and we'll call this firebase
and it says it's generated a boot file
in the source
boot folder and we can see it there and
it also says make sure to reference it
in quasar.com.js
and the boot section so i'm going to
open up quasar.com.js
and search for boot um we just need to
add firebase
to this array here and save that and now
let's open up this
firebase.js boot file and in a boot file
we can't access the
app the router and the view prototype
but we're not going to need any of that
stuff here so i'm just going to delete
all of this
and i'm going to jump back to that
firebase page
and copy this first example here
and paste that in here and i'll get rid
of all of these comments
and we only need to import the modules
that we need and we do need
firebase from firebase app but we don't
need analytics so i'll get rid of this
line
and we don't need auth we're not going
to be doing any authentication
but we do need firestore so i'll leave
that there
and i'll just get rid of these
semicolons because i've not been
generally using them and i'll jump back
to this firebase page
and it tells us how to initialize
firebase in our app
after we've imported all the modules we
need so i'll copy
this example and paste it into
our boot file and i'll get rid of these
comments
and that config object that we saw
before we need to put that in here
so i'm going to jump back to this other
page
which was displayed after we created the
web app
i'm going to copy everything inside this
config object
i'll just paste that in here there's one
more thing we need to do
if we jump back to that firebase page
and scroll down to
step five and if we jump to cloud
firestore which is what we're going to
be using and scroll down
to initialize cloud firestore so we just
need to fire this
firebase.firestore method and assign it
to a variable
so i'll just copy this line and paste
that to the bottom and i'll change
var to let and get rid of these
semicolons
and this db variable will give us access
to our firestore database
so we want to export that so that we can
use it anywhere within our app
so i'm just going to add export default
and then db
and save that and this boot file should
be ready to go now
and we should now have access to our
firestore database with this db variable
so i'm just going to launch our app with
quasar dev make sure we don't have any
errors
and it's launched our app and we don't
have any errors so let's grab the queets
that we created in our database and
display them in our app
[Music]
let's grab our queets from our quits
collection in our database
and display them within our app so i'm
going to jump to the firebase docs page
and over on the left here under cloud
firestore i'm going to go to
read data i'm going to jump to listen
for real time updates
i'm going to scroll down to view changes
between
snapshots and this code sample here
will allow us to add real-time data sync
to our app across our devices because
this
on snapshot here is a hook and this hook
will be fired every time the data in the
collection that we specify here
changes and we can determine exactly
what happened
whether a document was added or modified
or removed and then we can fire code
to update our view accordingly so let's
say we're using our app
and somebody else say jim is also using
our app
and they add a new quite well this on
snapshot hook will be fired
on our device and we can determine that
a quit was added
and we can then add that quit that was
added by jim
to our view and likewise if jim modifies
or removes a quit
this hook will be fired and we can
update our view on our device
accordingly
so it's using hooks like this in
firebase which makes real-time data sync
across devices
possible so i'm going to copy this
example
and i'm going to jump back to our code
and first we need to get access to this
db variable in our home page so i'm
going to jump to pagehome.view and then
at the top of the script section
i'm going to import db from and then the
path
to our boot file which is source slash
boot
slash firebase and we don't need to put
in the
dot js and then we want to trigger this
hook that we just copied
and we could do this in a mounted hook
i'm just going to collapse the data
and the methods and the filters we'll
add a mounted hook at the bottom here
before we paste in this hook i'm just
going to clear out the hard-coded quets
that we added
so i'll just comment out these quits
here
and save that so that we know that any
quets that appear here are coming from
our database and i'm going to jump back
down to this
mounted hook and paste in this code
sample
i'm just going to fix the indentation a
bit so this is going to access our
database
and it's going to grab the collection
that we specify here
and our collection is called quits
so we want to put quits in here i'm just
going to change these double quotes into
single quotes and this dot where method
is going to
filter our results by some criteria
and we don't need to do that we just
want to grab all of our quits so i'll
get rid of this
where method i'm just going to move this
on snapshot
up to this line and nudge everything
back
so we're going to grab our quits
collection and then every time that
quits collection changes
this on snapshot method will be fired
which will return a snapshot of all of
our data and then we can get an array of
all of our changes by firing this
dot changes method on the snapshot and
then we're basically just
looping through each of those changes
and each of those changes will be an
object
which will have a type property which
will tell us
the type of change so whether a document
was added
modified or removed and we can also get
access to the data which was
added modified or removed so i'm just
going to do a little bit of formatting
here
i'm going to select all these double
quotes and replace them with
single quotes because that's generally
what i've been using
and i'm going to get rid of any
semicolons because i've not been using
them
i'm going to update the text in these
console logs
so instead of new city i'm going to put
new quit
and modified quit and removed queet
so let's save this and see what gets
logged out
so i'll reload the page and open up the
console
and we can see new quick being logged
out four times
for each of our tweets because we have
four in our database
because this if statement here will be
fired in real time whenever a document
is added to our database
but it will also be fired once for each
document in our database
when we first connect to the database
which is why we're seeing these logs
here
and we have the data for each of our
quits so what we can do here in this
if statement is just push the data
object for each of our quits
to our quits array in our data and so
our data is in here
in change.data so instead of firing this
out
three times like that i'm going to put
that in a variable
at the top of this for each so i'll set
up a variable
called quit change set that equal to
this
change.data and i'll replace all of
these
with this variable so quit change
and so what we can do now in this added
if statement
is just add this quick change object to
our quits array and we should then see
each of the tweets appear on the page
so what we can do here is this dot quits
on shift and pass in
quit change uh let's save that and see
if it's working
i'll just reload that uh it doesn't seem
to be working cannot read property quits
of undefined
and that's because these functions here
are normal
javascript functions so when we use the
this
keyword it will refer to this function
here
instead of our view instance so we can
just change these functions to arrow
functions
so i'm just going to get rid of function
and the first
parentheses and get rid of this
parentheses
and i'll just add an arrow there and
i'll do the same on this
function as well let's save that and try
it again
uh we can now see our tweets on the page
however these tweets are not in the
correct order because this one at the
top here
is from two hours ago and these other
ones are from one hour ago
so we want to order these by date and if
we jump back to the firebase page
and jump to order and limit data we can
use this
order by method to order our data by a
particular field
so after db.collection quits i'm going
to add
dot order by uh we can just pass in date
i'll save that and our quits are now in
the correct order we see that all this
one
down at the bottom and this if statement
here will now be fired
whenever a quit is added to our
collection in the database
and so just to demonstrate that i'm
going to jump to the database
and drag it over here and just drag this
over a little bit
and i'll add a new quit here i'll use
auto id
add the content field i'll just grab a
quote from that
extension paste that in there add the
date field
set that to a number and i'm just going
to use date dot now
to grab the current date
and paste that in here and hopefully
when i click save we should see this new
quit
appear in our list of quits at the top
there
so i'll click on save and we see that
new quit appear
[Music]
let's add the ability to add a tweet to
our database to our quick collection
when the user clicks this button
because right now it's just adding the
quick to our local
quits array and so we do see it here but
if we
refresh the page then that data is gone
so i'm going to jump to the
add new quick method which is fired when
we click this button
and that's here so we still want to set
up a new
object like this and we still want to
clear out this new quick content
property which
clears out this input but we no longer
want to add this new object
directly to our local quits array here
what we want to do instead is add this
nucle object
straight to our firebase database to our
quick collection
because when we do that this on snapshot
hook will be fired
because we made a change to our
collection and change.type will be equal
to
added so this if statement will fire and
at that point the new quick will be
added
to our local quits array and then
displayed on the page
so we'll jump back up to this add new
creep method and i'll comment out this
line
and what we want to do at this point is
add this new quee object
straight to our quits collection in the
database so i'm going to jump back to
the firebase docs page
and i'm going to go to add and manage
data and add data
i'm going to scroll down to add a
document
and there are two ways we can add a
document to a collection
we can use this set method but if we use
that method then we need to
specify the id where that document
should be stored
but if you want to add a document and
let firebase generate the id
for us then we can use this add method
so i'm just going to copy this
code sample here and we'll paste it here
in our add new creep method and i'll
just fix the indentation
i'm going to replace all the double
quotes with single quotes
and i'm going to remove the semicolons
we want to access the quits collection
so i'll change this here to quits
and the data that we want to add is just
this new quit
object so we can just select this object
in here
i'll just paste in new quite
and i'm just going to format this a
little bit i'm going to move the then
block
up here then i'm going to move this
catch block up here
okay so let's save that and see if it's
working so i'll add a new
quit i'll
click the button uh yeah we see it
appear on the page
uh let's just make sure it's been added
to the database
and yeah we can see it there uh let's
make sure we can still see it if we
reload and yeah we do
let's add the ability to delete a quick
from our quits collection
in our database and before we handle
actually removing a quick from the
database when this delete button
is clicked let's handle removing a quick
from our local
quits array in this on snapshot hook
in this if statement here and we want to
make all of our local
state changes or all of our local data
changes
inside this hook the reason being again
just to remind you
this on snapshot hook will be fired
every time the database changes
so even if somebody on a completely
different device adds modifies or
deletes equate
this on snapshot hook will be fired on
our device
and so we can add modify or remove the
appropriate
quet from our local state and update our
view
accordingly so it's making local state
changes in this hook
and only in this hook which makes live
data sync
across devices possible and so if equate
is removed from our database then this
if statement should be fired
and we should see this console log being
fired out
so let's manually remove a quick from
our database
and see what we see so i'm going to drag
the
database over here and open up the
console
in our app i'll just clear the console
uh let's delete one of these quits so we
can just click on these buttons here and
click on delete document
and click on start delete uh we can see
that log being fired out
and we can see the data for that quick
we can see the content property and the
date property
so now what we want to do at this point
here
is remove the same quick from our local
quits array
thus removing it from the view and we
could remove it from our local
quits array based on the date property
however there's always the chance
that multiple tweets could have the same
date
so it would be better if we could delete
the tweet
based on these ids which have been
generated by firebase instead because
these ids will always be
unique but we don't currently have
access to these ids right now we only
have access to the content property
and the date property however if we jump
back to our
on snapshot hook then we can actually
get access to the id
at change.doc.id like this
change.id so let's add this id
to our quick change object here which
currently just contains
the content and date properties so what
we can do
is add a new property to this quick
change object
and id property and set it to this id
so we can just do quit change
dot id equals change dot dot dot id
so i'll save that and hopefully now when
equate is removed from the database
we should see the id in this
quick change object as well
so let's delete a document from our
quits collection
and see if we can see the id being
logged out
so i'll click on this and click on
delete document
and start delete we can see the quit
object being logged out
and we can now see the id as well in
this new
id property and we should see the ids in
our local quits array as well
so if i go to view devtools and
try and find this page q page container
and page home
we can see our quits array here we do
have the ids
and currently if i jump back to page
home dot view
on our list of quits we're still using
the date property as the key
and it would be better to use these ids
instead because we know they're always
going to be unique
so i'm just going to change the key to
quit id
instead and save that okay so now that
we have the id
of the quit that was deleted we can use
that id to
remove the same quet from our local
quits array
so i'm going to jump back down to uh on
snapshot hook
and this if statement here uh let's
start by
finding the index of the same queen in
our local array
so i'll add let index and then we can do
this dot quits
dot find index pass in a placeholder
and a callback and we want to find the
index of the queen where the quit
dot id is equal to the id in this
quick change object so i'll just put
quit change dot id
so that should give us the index and we
can then just
use the splice method to remove the quit
at this position from the array so we
can just do this.quits
dot splice pass in the index
and pass in one so that we only remove
one item
and let's save that and see if it's
working i'll just reload the page
and then clear the console and open up
the
firebase console let's delete a tweet
so we'll delete this top one here so
i'll delete that
and hopefully we should see it disappear
from the view
and now we also want to delete a tweet
from our database
when this delete button is clicked as
well because right now it's just
deleting a quick from our local quits
array but not from the database
so let's jump to our delete quite method
which is here and i'm just going to
remove everything inside
this method and let's find out on the
firebase docs page
how we can delete a document from our
collection so
over on the left here i'm going to jump
to add and manage data and then delete
data
and so to delete a document we just need
to
specify the collection as usual and
specify
the document that we want to delete so
we pass the
document id into here and then we just
fire this delete method
so let's copy this example and paste it
into this deletequit method
i'm just going to fix the indentation
remove the semicolons
and replace the double quotes with
single quotes
and so we want to access the quits
collection now we need to pass the
document id that we want to delete in
here and we're passing in the quit
object of the quit that was clicked
in here and so we have access to the id
of the quick that was clicked at
queet.id
so we can just pass quit.id in here
and so hopefully this should work now so
i'll save that
reload clear the console and i'll click
on this delete button
yeah it looks like it worked we saw it
removed from the view and we see
document successfully deleted which is
coming from the
then block on this delete method uh
let's make sure it was removed from the
database
and yeah we only have one document in
the database now okay so we've almost
finished our app now there's just one
more thing that i want to do
[Music]
so we can create read and delete our
quits
but we can't currently update them so
let's complete our crud set up by adding
the ability to
update a quite one thing we could do is
add the ability to
like a quet when this heart button is
clicked
here so first let's just set up the
front end for this
because if a quit is light then we
probably want this heart icon to be
filled i'll maybe give it a color as
well so i'm going to delete all of the
tweets that are on firebase i'm just
going to drag this
back over here we only have one document
left
i'm going to delete this quick because
we're going to need to add a new
field to our quits so i'm going to
delete this
and jump back to our app and i'm going
to uncomment these
hard-coded tweets that we added before
i'm going to add a new property to each
of these
called liked and i'll set one of these
to false
and then the other one to true and we're
also going to need to add some id
properties now
because our v4 loop is now using
an id property as the key so let's just
add some
dummy ids here so i'll just set these to
id1
and id2 and i'll save that
and so this quit here is the one that's
light
one where light is set to true so we
want this heart icon to
look a bit different i would like it to
be a filled icon if possible
and a different color as well so we got
this
icon from font awesome so i'm going to
jump to the quasar site
and then the icon page
and then i'll jump through to font
awesome
search for heart and scroll down so this
is the one we're currently using
but when a tweet is liked we could use
this filled version
so i'll click on that and i'll copy this
example here
let's jump up to this heart icon
which is here and for now i'm just going
to paste out this
html that we copied down here
so if the liked property is set to true
then we want to set this icon prop to
these classes here
otherwise we want to set them to these
classes so what we could do here
is bind to the icon prop and add a
ternary if statement here
so if quit dot liked
is true then we can spit out these
classes
so i'll paste that in these quotes here
otherwise
stretch this out a bit we can spit out
these classes here
and i'll just get rid of this icon prop
i'll get rid of this i tag as well
let's save that and see if it's working
yeah this second one
has a filled heart and the other one
still has the outline heart and i'd also
like to
change the color as well so what we
could do is bind to this color prop
so colon colour and again if quetz.liked
is true then we could try out putting
pink as the color
otherwise we'll just output gray and
i'll get rid of this
color prop and save that and yeah it
seems to be working we now have this
lovely pink heart okay so our front end
is now ready to display quits which are
liked
so let's comment out these hard-coded
quits
in this quick array and save that and
when we add a new quit
now we're going to have to make sure
that tweet object that we pushed to
the database has this new light property
so i'm going to jump to add new quick
this method and when we
set up the new quit object here we also
need to add this
light property and that should be set to
false by default
so i'll save that and reload
uh let's just add some quits here and
make sure
that the quits in the database have this
new
light property so i'm just going to use
this quotes extension to
add a load of quotes
uh let's jump to the database you can
see our new documents here
and yeah they all have this light field
so let's change one of them to true
and update that and reload the page
and yeah we can see this one has our
pink and filled heart
so before we handle the click event on
this button
let's just make sure our view gets
updated
when this on snapshot hook is fired when
a quit
has been modified so let's first of all
grab the
index of the tweet that was modified in
our local quits array
so i'm just going to copy this line here
from the removed
if statement and paste that here so this
will give us the index
of the quick that was modified and the
modified data will be in this
quick change object so what we could do
is use
object assign to copy the data from this
object
which has come from the database to the
quit
object in our local quits array
at the position of index
thus updating the appropriate quite in
the view
so what we can do here is object dot
assign
and first we want to pass in the object
that we want to assign to
which is the object in our local quits
array at the position of index
so we can just do this dot quits square
brackets
index and the second parameter we pass
in the data that we want to copy
here so we can just pass in quick change
i'll save that and reload the page
and if we jump to the database let's
drag it over here
and this document where light is set to
true this one here
let's change this back to false and we
should hopefully see
this heart change back to the
deactivated version so i'll set this to
false then click
update and yeah it seems to be working
i'll just change it back to true again
and yeah that all seems to be working so
i'll set this back to
false okay so now all we need to do
is handle the click on this heart icon
so when the user clicks this button
then we want to update the appropriate
tweet
in our quits collection on firebase so
i'm going to jump to
this heart button which is here and add
a click handler
so at click and this is going to be a
toggle because we're going to be able to
toggle between
light and not light so we'll trigger a
method called
toggle light and we'll pass in our qui
object so that we have access to the id
in this method because we're going to
need that to update the appropriate quit
on firebase and we'll create this method
in our methods object
so toggle quet pass in the queet
and for now let's just log out toggled
actually i've spelt that wrong that
should be toggle
quick so we'll just log out toggle quit
here
we'll log out the tweet as well so save
that
uh reload uh click on one of these heart
buttons
toggle light is not a function let me
just jump back to that click handler
uh this should be toggle light so save
that
i'm still seeing an error here why is
that
oh this should be toggle lights not
toggle queen so i'll just update that
okay save that let's reload uh click on
one of these
like buttons yeah we can see toggle
light
we can see the tweet that was clicked
we have the id there so we can use that
to
update the appropriate tweet in our
quick collection
on firebase so i'm going to jump back to
the firebase docs
i'm going to jump to add data and update
a document so again we just do
db.collection and the name of the
collection
then we fire the doc method and pass in
the id
of the document we want to update let me
just fire this
update method and pass in an object with
the new
data so i'm just going to copy all of
this
and paste it into this toggle light
method and instead of having this ref in
a variable i'm just going to copy
this ref and paste it here
get rid of this comment and get rid of
that var i'm just going to
fix the indentation get rid of these
semicolons
and replace the double quotes so we want
to do db.collection
and we want to pass quits in here and
then we want to pass the id
of the document that we want to update
in here and that's going to be our quit
dot id so we can just put queen.id in
here
what do we want to update we want to
update the light
property and we want to set it to the
opposite of this quite's
current liked property so if that's
currently false we want to set
it to true and if it's currently true we
want to set it to false
so we can just set liked to the opposite
of
queet.liked okay so let's save that and
see if it's working
i'm gonna reload the page uh right now
none of our tweets are liked
let's click on a like button and it
seems to have worked we see it change
in the view and we see documents
successfully updated
which means this then block is being
fired and let's make sure it worked on
firebase
so it was this tweet here and yeah light
is set to true
let's make sure we can toggle it back
again
oh yeah we saw that change on firebase
there okay we're almost ready to start
deploying this up to
different platforms we just have a
couple of tiny little issues that we
need to fix
okay we just have a couple of final
issues to fix
and the first one is when we're looking
at this in the mobile view
when we click on this button our left
draw is all
messed up and this is being caused by
this
full screen class which we added to this
cue scroll area
which is surrounding everything that's
on our home page because if we
inspect this element and look for this
scroll area which is here and we look at
this
full screen class it's adding a z index
of 6000
which is placing this q scroll area
above the left draw however there's some
other classes that we can use instead of
this
full screen class if you go to this
other css helper classes page
on the quasar site we can use this
full height class and this full width
class instead
to make the cue scroll area full width
and full height
without adding that z index so i'm just
going to replace this
full screen class on the cue scroll area
with full width
and full height and save that
let's reload the app and that's now
fixed
let's just make sure this cue scroll
area is still okay if we have a load of
tweets
so i'll just add a load of new
and it still looks okay
and it looks okay on desktop as well and
the other issue we need to fix
is to do with our on snapshot hook
this hook is currently being initialized
every time we hit the home page
so if i reload the page we see all these
new logs from firebase or if we clear
the console
and jump to the about page and jump back
to the home page
we see them all being logged out again
and also if i clear the console
and click on a like button you can see
this modified quit
log being logged out twice and that's
because we visited this home page
twice so this hook has been set up
two times and we only want to set this
hook up once
and never again after that and we can
fix this quite easily
by just making the pages of our app keep
alive
in the background so that when we
navigate from page to page the page that
we just left
keeps alive keeps running but we just
don't see it and to do this we want to
go to main layout.view
on this cue page container component and
this router view component here
is where our pages are rendered and if
we want to make this router view
keep alive thus making our pages keep
alive
then we can just surround this in keep
alive tags
like this so i'll save that and i'll
reload the app
so we see all of our new create logs and
if i jump to
the about page i'll just clear the
console and then back to the home page
then we don't see those logs again and
if i click on a like button
we only see one log from our on snapshot
hook so let's just make sure everything
is working
in both desktop view and mobile view
so we'll do desktop first so i'll reload
the app
and we can navigate our pages we can
toggle
the left draw and our quick button is
disabled when there's no text in here
let's just make sure the character limit
is working
yeah that's working we can add a quick
uh we can like a quit we can delete a
quit
if we reload the quick that we just
deleted has been removed
let's just check everything in mobile
view i'm going to use the device
toolbar and set this to iphone 678 plus
so i'll reload the app okay so we can
toggle the left draw and we can navigate
our pages
uh let's make sure the character count
is working
yeah that's working um we can add a
quick
uh we can like a quit uh we can delete
a create as well okay so quitter is now
complete and it's working great in the
browser
in both desktop layouts and mobile
layouts
so it's finally time to create some real
apps out of this sucker
for ios android mac and windows
let's get quitter running as a mac up
and you do need to have a mac in order
to do this
and if you're on a mac this is super
simple you just need to jump to your
terminal
i'm going to open up a new terminal
because i want to keep the web version
running
and then we just need to run quasar dev
dash
m for mode electron because quasar
desktop apps use the
electron framework and i'll just fire
that
and we can now see quitter running as a
markup and by the way if you're on
windows and you run the command that we
just ran
you should see the windows version of
the app launching in development mode
and if we go to view and toggle
developer tools
we can even open up some developer tools
for the mac version of our app
and one thing that's really great is
that we now even have
view dev tools integrated and this
wasn't here the last time i checked
so this is pretty badass and we're
seeing the mobile layout by default
because this window is a little bit
small by default
although we can resize it up but what we
can do to fix that
is set a width for this browser window
and set a minimum width as well
so i'm going to jump to the code and if
we look in our project
we can see quasar has generated a new
folder source electron
and if we go to main process on electron
dash main
we can use this file to customize all of
the stuff that happens in the main
process
so the native app side of the process
and we can do
all sorts of stuff here so we can
customize these menus
at the top add our own menus and options
and trigger code when those options are
clicked on
we can set up a menu bar icon for our
app up here
we can interact with the user's file
system and all sorts of stuff but for
now i'm just going to give this
browser window a width and a minimum
width as well
so i'm going to scroll down this file
and here's where it's
initializing our browser window and you
can see these width and height
properties here and if you want to see
all of the available options
then just google electron browser window
and jump to this page and you can find
all of the different options here
so there's tons of stuff we can do and
we do have a
min width property and a min height
property
so i'm just going to set this width
property to 1024
which i think is the starting width of
our desktop layout
i'll also add a min width property and
set it to the same 1024
if i save that it will relaunch our app
and it's made our window a little bit
bigger and we now see the desktop layout
and we can resize it up but we can't
resize it any smaller than 1.024
okay so let's make sure everything is
working so we can get to
our two pages we can toggle the left
draw
we can display all of our quits and
scroll down them
let's see if the character limit and
counter are working
and yeah they're working and we can add
a new quit
we can like a quit and we can delete a
quit
as well i'll just demonstrate the live
data sync across
devices and when i launched the mac
version it did kill
my browser version so i just had to jump
back to the terminal
with the browser version running and
kill the process and run
quasar dev again but if i just get the
electron version on the left and the
browser on the right
and if i add a new tweet here hey
what's going on i'll click on quit
we see the same tweak pop up instantly
on the mac version
and likewise if i like equate on the mac
version
we see it update instantly on the web
version and if i delete equate on the
map version we see it deleted instantly
on the browser version so we now know
for sure that all of our cross device
live data sync is working
[Music]
let's get this running as a windows app
and if you're on windows then you can
just run the command that i ran before
quasar dev dash m electron but i'm on a
mac here
so i'm going to build the windows
version for production
and then i'm going to launch it in a
windows 10 virtual machine
and to get quasar to build the windows
version we need to make a change to our
config file
so i'm going to open up quasar.com.js
and i'm going to search for electron
uh in this packager option here we need
to add an option
of platform and we need to set that to
win 32 and save that and now we just
need to go to the terminal and instead
of running quasar dev
dash m electron we run quasar build
m electron so i'll fire that
okay it says build succeeded and by the
way if it doesn't succeed
then you might be able to fix this by
just deleting your node modules folder
and running npm install and then running
the build command again
and it says it's i'll put it to the dist
slash
electron folder and we can see that disk
folder here
and this electron folder and our windows
app is in here
stretch this out a bit and we can see
our exe file here
and i'm going to launch this exe in a
windows 10 virtual machine
i'm going to use virtualbox to do this
and there is a little bit of setup
involved here
you need to download virtualbox from
virtualbox.org so you need to download
and install
that and then you need to download a
windows 10 virtual machine
so if you just google windows 10
virtualbox
and jump to this page on the microsoft
site
then you can download a windows 10
virtual machine for virtualbox here
once that's downloaded and unzipped
you should see a couple of files like
this a vmdk
file and an ovf file and if there's a
third file
with the file extension mf then you want
to delete that file
because it can stop you from importing
the virtual machine
properly and then you just want to
double click this ovf file
and it should add the virtual machine to
virtualbox
and you also want to go to settings and
then shared folders
and you want to share the folder on your
mac where you keep all your projects by
clicking on this button here
so that you can get access to the
generated exe file
and then you can just launch your
virtual machine by double clicking on it
okay it's launched my virtual machine so
i'm going to go to
windows explorer then i'm going to go to
network
and we see this vbox server computer
if we go in there i can see the folder
that's on my mac
that i've shared with this virtual
machine so i'm going to go in there
and jump down to the quitter folder
uh dist and electron and
i'm going to copy this folder with our
app and paste it on the desktop
and then i'm going to jump into that
folder
and we can see the exe file there and
i'm going to launch that
and we now see quitter running as a
windows app
and this is going to be a little bit
slow because we're in a virtual machine
here
but on a real windows device the
performance would be much better
and let's just see if it's obeying our
minimum
width which we set in the process file
and it is
i can't resize it down any more than
that uh let's make sure everything is
working
so we can get to both of our pages we
can toggle
our sidebar and we don't have a line
along the top here
however quasar has some classes which
get added to the body
that you can use to target particular
platforms so what you could do is
add a border to the top of the app but
only on windows
just to make this look a little bit
better so we can display our quits
and we can scroll down them uh let's see
if we can add one let's check the
character counter as well and yeah that
seems to be working
i'll click on queen and it's added our
queen
and we can like equate and we can delete
a queet as well
let's create an ios version of quitter
and you do need to have a mac
to do this although as a side note a
couple of my students have told me that
they managed to create
ios and mac apps using a windows
computer
and i believe they used vmware and it's
not something that i've tried
so i can't confirm if it's possible but
it might be worth investigating
if you are on windows and you're
interested in creating ios and mac apps
but generally speaking you need a mac
and you also need to have xcode
installed
and you can download this from the mac
app store
although i recommend downloading it from
the apple developer site at
developer.apple.com
download more and you also need to have
cordova installed globally
because quasar mobile apps use the
cordova framework
and if you go to the quasar site and
quasar cli
and developing chord over apps and
preparation
shows you how to install code over there
so you just need to fire this command
and if you have trouble installing that
you might need to add sudo to the start
um once that's all set up we can then
launch our app in the ios simulator so
we just need to jump to our terminal
and run quasar dev dash m for mode
cordova dash capital t and
ios and it's asking for a call over
app id here and this id will be used by
the app stores if you decide to deploy
your app to
the app stores so you need to be 100
sure that this
id is unique and one way that you can
make sure it's unique is by using
a reverse domain style id such as
com.dannyconnell.quitter
it's pretty unlikely that somebody else
would have used this id
and it started up the ios simulator and
it's launched our app
as an ios app and shortly after it
started up
we can see the elements from our app but
then they disappear
and this might be because we're using
the ui webview
to basically display our app within this
native app that's been created by quasar
and it's highly recommended that you
install the wk webview plugin because
the older ui webview is now
deprecated and apple will soon begin
rejecting
apps which use the older webview
[Music]
and if you go to the quasar site and
search for wk
webview and jump to switching to ios wk
webview
tells us how to install this so
hopefully installing this will
fix this issue although weirdly if we go
to the about page
and back to the home page then it works
again
but anyway i'm just going to install
this plugin so i'm going to copy this
command
jump to the terminal we need to cd
into this source card over folder that
it's created
so cd source card over
i'll run that command i just copied and
that's installed
and we also need to add this preference
to the ios section of the cordova
config file and that's just in the root
of this
source code over file and that's here
config.xml
so i'm going to scroll down to this
platform
ios section i'm going to copy this
preference tag here
and paste that here and i'll save that
i'll cd back up to our project folder
and try running the dev command again so
quasar dev dash m cardover
t ios and while we're waiting i'm just
gonna
delete the app that it's already
installed
just to avoid any caching issues
now we'll just wait for this app to
start up so i've not been able to figure
out what's going on here
but i have just noticed that this
simulator is running a really old
version of ios
12.2 and the current version is 14
something
so let's try and launch this up on ios
14 and see if it works
so i'm just going to close this
simulator and kill this process
and to get a list of the available
simulators we can cd
into the source code over folder and run
cordova
run ios dash list
and it will give us a list of all of the
available simulators
so let's try the iphone 12 on ios
14.3 so what we can do here is copy this
device name and jump back up to our
project folder
and we can run the same command again
quasar dev dash m card over dash capital
t
ios but then we add an extra flag dash e
for emulator and then in quotes we can
just paste
this device name that we just copied
let's give that a try
and this time it started up the iphone
12 on ios 14.3
so fingers crossed it'll work on this
simulator uh great it seems to have
started up no problem
on the ios 14 simulator and just to
confirm that i'm just going to close the
app
and launch it again and yeah starting up
okay
and let's make sure everything is
working
so the left drawer is working and we can
get to our pages
you can see all of our quits and we can
scroll down them
no problem uh let's just make sure this
input is working
and yeah it's counting the characters
and just to check the character limit
i'm just gonna
copy the text from one of these other
tweets
and paste that in here
paste it again
and just type a few more characters
and yeah stopping us at 280 characters
and let's see if we can actually add the
tweet
yeah it seems to have added it no
problem and we can like
quits and we can delete them as well
[Music]
okay finally let's create an android
version of our app and there's a little
bit more setup involved
for android but if you go back to this
preparation for called overwrap
page on the quasar site which you can
find at
quasar cli developing chord overlaps and
preparation
it tells you everything you need to do
here so after installing card over
you need to download android studio and
follow some
installation steps and then after that's
installed you need to use this
sdk manager tool which comes with the
android sdk and use that to
accept some licenses and then you need
to add
the android installation to your path
and it gives you some instructions on
how to do this
on mac linux and windows
on windows you also need to install some
other software as well
but just read through all these steps
and follow them very carefully but i'm
just going to
launch android studio
then i'm going to click on this
configure button and go to the avd
manager
android virtual device manager and i
have an android virtual device set up
here
pixel 2 xl so i'm going to click on this
play button
to launch this emulator and now that the
emulator has fully started up
we can now launch our app on it so we
just need to go to our terminal
and instead of running quasar dev dash m
card over dash t
ios we want to run the same command but
with android after the capital t
flag
and we now have an android version of
our app and it seems to have launched
okay
let's make sure it's working so we can
get
to our different pages you can see all
of our tweets
we can scroll down them
let's see if we can add a quet
click the button and yeah it's added it
uh let's see if we can light them yep
seems to work
and delete yeah seems to be working as
well
so we created an app with a beautiful
front end
a nice simple back end and live data
sync across
all the different devices and we
deployed it to all these different
platforms
all thanks to the amazing quasar
framework as well as vue.js and
firebase and there's a lot more that you
would probably want to add to this app
such as adding a custom icon and splash
screen
and customizing the menus for the
electron app
handling errors and adding loading
screens
adding a settings page setting up some
kind of state management for the app
using something like
vue x and breaking up your app into
child components to make it more
manageable
and you can learn about many of these
things and more at my youtube channel
so please check it out at danny's dot
link slash youtube
and the link will be in the description
and huge thanks to free code camp for
hosting this video
and thanks to you for watching
[Music]
[Music]
you